We will begin by looking at all of the skeletal mesh components, which include the body, the
feet, the legs, the torso, and we will finish off with the face.
So let's jump back into Unroll Engine and take a closer look at each of these.
Let's begin by looking at the body component on the left over here.
When selected, in the Details panel on the right, we can see all of the properties and
assets associated with this component, such as the material and skeletal mesh.
If we open up the skeletal mesh, it will have skinning for the hands and ankles, as this
character also has clothes.
If we go up here to the top right and we select the Skeleton tab, it will open up the MetaHuman
based skeleton, which is shared by all MetaHumans.
It will always be the female medium normal body weight and it is located in the common
folder.
If I go to the Animation tab over here, I can search for mh body animation and select
it.
We can see this animation sequence in this window.
All of the animations over here are shared by all MetaHumans in the project, and this
is because they all share the MetaHuman based skeleton.
Let's return back to the MetaHuman blueprint.
And before we move on, let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
The body component has a skeletal mesh with its own material.
The skeletal mesh will have its own unique skinning and body proportion, and it will
be located in the folder with the name of your MetaHuman.
The MetaHuman based skeleton is shared by all MetaHumans in a project and is located
in the common folder.
This will always be the female medium normal body weight.
The body component also includes animation sequences, animation blueprints, and a physics
asset.
Now let's continue by taking a look at the feet and legs components.
Let's move on to the feet component.
If I select the feet, over here on the right, we can see that this has its own skeletal
mesh and material associated with it.
Since MetaHumans are modular, we are able to switch between skeletal meshes and groom
assets if we wish.
There are other MetaHumans that have been added to this project with their own unique
skeletal meshes for the feet, so we can switch between those by going over here.
For example, we could switch these boots out with flip flops, but keep in mind differences
in body proportions and skinning when replacing assets.
Now let's move on to the legs component.
In the Details panel on the right, this component will have its own skeletal mesh assigned and
its associated material.
There may be cases where you want to add additional custom clothing.
In this case, you can add a new skeletal mesh component.
To do this, go to the Add sign and search for skeletal mesh.
In the Details panel on the right, you would assign the skeletal mesh asset.
And then, with the skeletal mesh selected, you would drag this over the body to make
it a child of the body.
The next step is to go to the construction script.
Inside of here, drag the skeletal mesh component into the construction script.
We can see how all of the skeletal mesh components are connected to Enable Master Pose nodes
and are all set up to follow the body.
We will need to do the same for this skeletal mesh component.
To do this, select this Enable Master Pose node and press Ctrl D to duplicate it.
Then, connect the skeletal mesh component to the Enable Master Pose node.
And then connect this to the other master pose nodes so that it follows the body.
Now before we move on, let's review what we just covered.
For clothing components such as the feet and legs, you can replace these with custom skeletal
mesh assets.
Or, if you have metahumans in your project with different skeletal meshes for these components,
you can switch between them.
Just keep in mind differences in skinning and proportions.
If you want to create your own custom clothes, you can download the Maya file from the Quixel
Bridge standalone application and use the clothes as a starting point to get skinning
and LOD templates transferred to your skeletal mesh.
If you wish to add a skeletal mesh clothing component, ensure you make it a child of the
body component, then add it into the construction script, connect it to its own Enable Master
Pose node, and then connect it to the rest of the Enable Master Pose nodes so that it
follows the body.
Now let's continue by looking at the torso component.
I'm going to select it and go to the details panel and open up the skeletal mesh.
Some clothing assets will have physics such as this hoodie sweater.
If I go here to the top right and then go to the physics tab, inside of here we have
the physics asset for the hoodie.
On the left here we can select the hoodie strings or specific portions of the hoodie
strings.
On the right hand side in the details panel we can modify the physics properties.
Now if we go to the animation blueprint tab, this will open up the animation blueprint
of the hoodie.
Inside of here we can enable and disable the rigid body simulation and make other adjustments
to the LOD threshold for the rigid body and control rig.
If you want to have further control over the rigid body settings, you can do so in the
clothing post-process animation blueprint.
To access this I have the body skeletal mesh docked over here.
Inside of here I can go to the animation blueprint tab and drop this down and select
the clothing post-process animation blueprint.
Inside of here we can see how the rigid body node is set up and by selecting it we can
adjust its properties.
Now before we move on let's review what we just covered.
We just took a look at the torso component.
Some of the clothing assets such as the hoodie sweater may have physics.
The physics properties can be adjusted inside of the physics window of that skeletal mesh.
The clothing animation blueprint will allow you to enable and disable rigid body simulation
and control the LODs.
In the animation graph of the clothing post-process animation blueprint, the rigid body node allows
you to modify additional simulation properties.
Now let's continue by taking a look at the face component.
Let's move on to the face component.
In the details panel we will see that the face skeletal mesh has several materials assigned
to different portions of the face such as the skin, the eyes and so on.
Let's open up the skeletal mesh.
Now let's go here to character, select bones and select all hierarchy.
We can see that the face has a large number of joints.
I'm going to go back to character, then bones and set the joints to none.
Over here on the right in the morph target panel you will find that the metahuman face
also has a large number of blend shapes and corrective blend shapes.
Now let's go to the skeleton tab.
This will open up the face archetype skeleton which is shared by all metahumans and this
is located in the common face folder.
If we go to the blueprints tab, the face will have two animation blueprints.
The face NMBP which has dedicated AR kit and animation retargeting functions and the
face post process blueprint.
The face post process blueprint is where Rik logic and the net correctives are set up.
From here we can enable and disable certain features related to optimization and animation
quality.
Now before we move on let's review what we've just covered.
The face component assets include the face archetype located in the common face folder,
the face skeletal mesh which will be unique for your character, animation sequence assets
and animation blueprints.
The face post process animation blueprint is where the Rik logic node lives.
Rik logic is responsible for allowing animations to be shared across all metahumans and LODs.
It's also responsible for triggering corrective blend shapes and animated wrinkle maps when
animations are applied.
By disabling the face post process blueprint it will only trigger joint deformations which
will reduce the animation quality but improve performance.
Now let's move on and take a look at the groom components.